This episode is sponsored by Morning Brew.
Morning Brew is a free daily newsletter that
gets you up to speed on business news in just
5 minutes.
Click the link in the description to subscribe
now.
When it comes to moving, ciliates are spectacular
to watch.
Their hair-like cilia beat in waves that steer
them around the microcosmos, and that’s
great if you’re trying to get from Point
A to Point B. But sometimes you’re not actually
trying to get anywhere.
You’re just trying to be slightly less in
the spot you are currently in.
Like these spirostomum, which can grow several
millimeters in length.
That size can be an advantage when they’re
looking for food or navigating the world around
them, but it also makes them easy targets
for predators.
Same for the vorticella, which anchor themselves
to substrates and then extend their feeding
heads out into the microcosmos.
It makes them kind of like fishermen, waiting
for food to come by, but it also makes them
sitting ducks for predators.
But spirostomum, vorticella, and many other
ciliates do have a way of defending themselves
from these attacks: contracting.
Contracting is like very, very effective flinching.
If you accidentally touch a hot burner on
the stove, you flinch and pull your hand away
very quickly.
Now imagine if you could not only pull your
hand back, but you could actually shrink your
hand down into your arm to minimize the threat
of the stove even further.
Well, the microcosmos does not have stoves
(though, I guess it could be said that stoves
have a microcosmos—but that’s a story
for a different day).
Instead, microbes are caught up in a great
game of Marco Polo with predators, responding
to chemical and physical cues to detect possible
threats, and responding in their own ways.
Of course, there’s the tried and true chemical
defense, which spirostomum do use.
Scientists have documented a predator vomiting
up a spirostomum whose toxins didn’t digest
very well.
But while toxins are a great defensive option
to have, if you’re a spirostomum or any
other ciliate, you probably don’t want to
get to the point where you need to be vomited up.
Plus, even if you’ve managed to evade the
same predator again and again like spirostomum
has, there’s plenty of other obstacles to
avoid in the microcosmos.
Like poop.
I mean yeah, when you have video of Spirostomum
getting pooped on you have to use it.
Anyway...
Whether you are avoiding predators or their
poop, contracting is a good response to have.
And these contractions are marvelous.
They are some of the fastest things in nature
and not only do the contractions happen quickly,
but the time between when the stimulus is
received and the contraction begins is faster
than any action you have ever taken.
Scientists have been observing and documenting
different ciliates and their contractile behaviors
for decades now, and it’s not hard to understand
their fascination.
For one, the contraction looks a bit like
the movement of our own muscles, just much
much faster.
Though it turns out it works much differently.
And it’s also just very easy to get a ciliate
to contract.
And that turns out to be an important thing
when you want to study something.
Stentors have been a popular contractile ciliate
model because all you have to do to get them
from their distinctive trumpet shape to a
sphere is poke them with a glass needle.
Now, it’s important to note here that we’re
using this word “contraction” like it’s
a uniform behavior done in the same way in
all ciliates.
But just like how animals have a lot of different
ways to run around, ciliates have a lot of
different ways to contract.
Vorticella, for example don’t contract their
whole bodies, they spiralize their stalks,
which coil them towards whatever they’re
attached to, and away from whatever stimuli
has set them off.
And spirostomum have their own twist—a literal
one.
Specialized membrane structures and a long
coil of microtubles spin their ends, while
keeping their middle stable to activate contraction
in an ultra-fast movement that was only really
deeply understood in 2019.
Now again, whatever the change is for the
organism though, one of the things these species
share in common is that the contractions are
very, very fast—so much so that it’s taken
high speed cinematography for scientists to
start to figure out how it works.
Stentors, spirostomum, and vorticella all
condense to fractions of their original length
in a matter of milliseconds.
A contracting spirostomum can experience forces
of around 14g.
For comparison, an elite fighter pilot doesn’t
ever experience more than 9 gs of force.
And for vorticella, the rapid contraction
of their stalk moves them at about 1200 body
lengths per second.
That is very fast.
That’s the equivalent of a cheetah running
a mile in a second.
Now interestingly, while the organisms we’re
highlighting today work on the scale of milliseconds
to contract, they are much slower on the recovery,
taking more on the order of seconds to extend
back to their original state.
Now this makes sense, as the goal is to do
whatever possible to escape being eaten, so
the initial quick movement is more important
than the return to our normal activities movement.
But the factors driving this fast contraction
and slow relaxation are both physical and chemical.
Now physically, the bodies of these organisms
contain a mix of contractile fibers that work
together and against each other to create
these movements.
In stentors and spirostomum, you can see these
special membrane structures running along
their bodies.
And in the vorticella stalk, you can see this
helical, contracting organelle called the
spasmoneme.
Whatever these things look like, you can think
of any of these movements not as sudden contractions
of muscle fibers, but instead, as chemicals
that change shape in different chemical conditions.
If the solution they are in has a bunch of
calcium ions, the structures are small and
tightly coiled, if the solution has a low
concentration of calcium ions, they stretch out.
And so, in all of these cases, mechanical
stimulation causes these cells to suddenly
and rapidly allow calcium ions into the cell,
which causes all these structures to dramatically
and rapidly change shape.
But in order to return to the original shape,
the calcium ions have to be slowly and carefully
pumped out of the cytoplasm.
So, calcium ions are used across all of biology
to carry information and cause changes in
all kinds of biological systems, including
the biological system that is you.
But this reliance on calcium ions is kind
of strange.
It’s very common.
But the evolution of these systems relying
on calcium is a little weird because calcium
ions can interfere with reactions that are
key to our cellular metabolism.
One recent theory to try and reconcile this
contradiction is that the rapid, calcium-driven
responses we are looking at right now are
part of a much longer evolutionary arc—one
built on the need for ancient cells to repair
damage to their membranes in order to prevent
a fatal influx of calcium ions from their
surroundings.
The same urgency that could have driven the
evolution of this biological first aid kit
might have then been rewired for other rapid
sensors.
And if this theory is correct, it means that
nature converted a defense against a chemical
into a signaling mechanism that drives everything
from the contractions you are watching, to
the action potentials that are helping you
understand the words that you are hearing right now.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We would also like to thank Morning Brew again
for sponsoring this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Do you like to begin your mornings by aimlessly
scrolling social media, trying to find all
of the news that you may have missed while
you were sleeping and never really sure whether
you’re getting it, and oftentimes, finding
stuff that you don’t actually need to be
looking at, but looking at it anyway and then
just not feeling better afterward.
Well, I know that I do.
With their daily newsletter, Morning Brew
is here to bring you witty, relevant, and
informative business news all in one place,
and they make it easy for you to get up to
speed in just 5 minutes.
The newsletter is written to be accessible
and include all of the need-to-know information
to get your day started.
Like, they recently had a newsletter feature
that condensed the key takeaways from the
IEA’s latest report on reaching net zero
emissions by 2050 and the milestones that
governments will need to hit to make that
goal achievable.
If you’re interested in business, finance,
or tech, there’s no reason not to subscribe
to Morning Brew. it’s completely free and
it takes less than 15 seconds to subscribe.
Click the link in the description below to
subscribe to Morning Brew.
The people you’re seeing on the screen right
now, they are our patrons on Patreon.
They’re the reason that we can make this
show so thank you so much to all of them.
Now, normally, this is the part where we’d
tell you to check out our Master of Microscope’s
James Weiss’s Instagram, Jam & Germs, but
right now, instead, we want to make sure that
we tell you that tomorrow (as of the day this
video is going live) James’s book The Hidden
Beauty of the Microscopic World will be out
and available wherever books are sold!
We’re so happy and excited for James.
It’s a beautiful thing.
There’s a link in the description.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.